in the United States the function of
Healthcare in America is not to provide
quality care to all it's to make
billions for the insurance companies so
strengthen the NR NHS you need more
money put money into it but don't go the
American route we're trying to get out
of that the labor party in the UK one of
the ways that they're looking at
potentially strengthening the NHS is
more Partnerships with the private
sector using spec capacity in the
private sector I would be nervous about
that I don't know all the details but it
sounds to me like the wrong direction
really you because the private sector
you think is look the function of the
private sector is not to provide quality
care what the function of Health Care is
not complicated everybody should be
entitled to the best care the system can
provide
uh not to have a system in which
insurance companies make make huge
amounts of money